Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my new Marvel Ben Affleck video there's a
big announcement about Marvel bringing
him on for a big villain role in the
MCU so obviously big announcement
Ben Affleck coming back to Marvel
never come back as his version of Daredevil
because we have Avengers six secret words coming
and that's going to be a big Multiverse movie with
a bunch of cameos from old movies like The Fox
Marvel movies you also have Toby Maguire Andrew
Garfield coming back from the Sony Spider-Man
movies but the character that they want him for
is very different than anything he's ever played
in any of the Marvel or the DC movies so I'll
explain what's going on if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos because as I'm posting this it's towards
the end of the year we're getting ready for a
bunch of really big Marvel Phase 5 stuff to debut
in 2023 it is the beginning of Marvel phase 5. we
will get a couple big new trailers after the New
Years just because the big celebration so you may
have seen that Marvel is trying to get Ben Affleck
as Dario agger in the Marvel Phase 5 movies
it's not for Thor 5 even though Dario agger's
typically associated with the Thor characters he
showed up in one of his biggest stories during
a Thor Comic book that was actually part of the
Jane Foster Mighty Thor Comics that right after
her initial debut in the comment a couple of years
ago also after the gore the god butcher storyline
but right now Jane Foster is dead and they're
not bringing her right back anytime soon and
they're not planning on doing Thor 5 during Marvel
Phase 5 at least even though Chris Hemsworth has
said that he will do Thor five he's coming back
for more Marvel movies but the tone of Thor 5
will be radically different from Thor love and
thunder it won't be as comedic as with taika
waititi did with the movie and he's also probably
not going to come back in Direct Thor five it'll
probably be somebody totally different it's for
a totally different movie I'll explain which in
a second Dario agger mostly known as the head of
Roxanne a Natural Resources company called rocks
and energy it's been referenced a billion times
across a bunch of Marvel movies and a bunch of
Marvel TV shows before the war there were only
three refiner is capable of something like this
Franklin chemical and eagle star converted
to diesel so that only leaves rocks on right
this has to be 200 Acres you've probably seen it
mentioned in the background on some sign on some
building somewhere in one of the TV series of the
movies even as far back as the agent Carter series
set during the 1940s 1950s they even referenced
them as recently as the She-Hulk series on one
of the gas stations they're one of the many evil
corporations inside the Marvel universe that are
trying to exploit as many natural resources as
possible like oil gas precious metals diamonds
gold semiconductors all that kind of stuff even
though the director of Ant-Man 3 Quantum Mania
said they weren't going to completely pay off
that Sonny Birch Easter egg from Ant-Man and
the Wasp where he said that he wanted Quantum
energy for a mysterious quote-unquote buyer with
billions billions of dollars to spend that's part
of something completely separate that they'll pay
off in a different movie Dario agger roxoxn would
be one of the companies with billions of dollars
like that to spend and want Quantum energy as well
so they basically try to do anything they can to
mine every precious resource on this planet or
any other planet outside of Earth during the
eternals movie Cersei also made sure to leave
a giant Stone Celestial tiamit in the Indian
Ocean in its bristling with cosmic energy Advanced
Cosmic medals all kinds of resources that planet
Earth doesn't either know about yet or knew
about and are super rare just because of the
way celestial's bodies work it is like the new
biggest natural resource on planet Earth ripe
for the taking everybody with any kind of interest
in that is looking for it in Marvel phase five is
a bigger plot point during Marvel Phase 5 just
in general finally gonna see them do something
with that giant Stone Celestial even though there
was a joke about it during She-Hulk it came during
the scene where she was browsing the internet and
within that scene on her web page they had jokes
about a bunch of different Marvel references even
the Wolverine character like man with metal claws
gets in bar fight like ah they're referencing the
very first Brian Singer X-Men movie Wolverine we
know now Hugh Jackman is coming to the MCU but in
a very different kind of way how are you you have
questions yes I I add a lot of questions I'm sure
you had a lot of questions but rest assured we're
going to answer them right now like for example
how is Wolverine alive yeah after Logan because
of the way Deadpool 3 is invoking the T TVA time
travel to mess with the timeline many timelines
destroy quote-unquote timelines destroy the fox
Marvel Universe it is possible that reference
could turn into a Deadpool 3 reference but I don't
know if they were making that when they wrote it
that way but on the page you see a joke about a
giant Stone man the people are confused about you
have to imagine if they were trying to be more
real world with this like how would the world
actually react to a giant Stone Celestial like
that there would be so many Instagram and social
media influencers trying to get pics of themselves
on that it'd be crazy forget about all the people
like Thunderbolt Ross and the world governments
trying to get their hands on it to weaponize it
the reason why Dario agger's typically thought of
is a big villain is because he literally sold his
soul to gain the powers of the mythical Minotaur
from Greek mythology he was born in Greece to Rich
parents he spent most of his life on an island in
the Aegean Sea when he was nine his parents were
killed by Pirates he escaped hidden a nearby cave
prayed for help and when the Pirates found him in
front of a statue of a bull the next morning his
prayers were answered and he was transformed into
the Minotaur here's where we get to our villain
origin story though instead of using those brand
new powers of the Minotaur to kill them he
actually kept the Pirates alive and continued
to torture them for the rest of their lives then
using his new power and the wealth given to him
through his parents he just continued to grow up
into like a version of Norman Osborne who's more
concerned with natural resources he became
the CEO of rocks and energy whereas someone
like Norman Osborne is more of a scientist
you know I'm something of a scientist myself
but he's the same type of Personality as someone
like Norman Osborne it's the same type of vibe
someone who is cold calculating very good at their
job very good at making money but also wants to
exploit the world Marvel's already largely cast
the earlier Marvel Phase 5 movies in either finish
filming them or are almost completely done filming
them so I think they're trying to get Ben Affleck
as Dario agger for one of the later Marvel Phase
5 movies or early Marvel phase six and based on
what's happening at the end of Marvel phase five
they might want him for the Thunderbolts movie
The only reason why I say Thunderbolts and not
something like Captain America 4 because that's
a huge movie is because they're already doing so
much stuff in Captain America 4 and they have so
many huge actors in that movie they're introducing
a new version of The Avengers team finally they're
introducing the Thunderbolts For the First Time
Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross they're also introducing
the recast version of Harrison Ford as Thunderbolt
Ross and he's going to become the president of the
United States in that movie and it sounds like
they're also using it to pay off part of the
Bruce Banner Planet Hulk storyline with cigar that
we saw at the end of the She-Hulk series as far
as him coming back as a version of his Daredevil
from the Multiverse in Avengers 6 Secret Wars It's
always possible they did make lots of references
to the Ben Affleck Daredevil movie if you don't
remember in the Ben Affleck Daredevil movie
John Favreau played a version of foggy Nelson
listen this eyewitness is saying that Casada was
singled out by the Demonic vigilante known as the
Daredevil I don't know why you read that trash
I've been hearing stories about this guy for
years it's got to be something to it but like the
alligators and the sewers there are alligators in
the sewers don't ride my ass about the alligators
I got a friend in sanitation okay seen them when
they had the scene with happy Hogan John Favreau
and Charlie Cox Daredevil they made a bunch of
references to that other version of Daredevil
John Favreau said on the day too there's a lot of
deleted scenes that they didn't include on the DVD
and they haven't released anywhere where they just
continue to make jokes about that other version
of Daredevil happy stop sweating how do you do
that the other Big Ben Affleck announcement you
may have seen recently is because of all the DC
stuff Ben Affleck Batman James Gunn taking over
DC rebooting all the DC movies and announcing
what some of the first ones are going to be in
a couple weeks is part of all of James Gunn's
announcements he also said that he had just talked
to Ben Affleck about coming back to direct a new
DC movie and he made it sound like it was a pretty
done deal they just hadn't found out which movie
it was going to be it's not going to be one of
the new Batman movies because that's still going
to be Robert Pattinson Batman Matt Reeves is still
directing all those movies but the whole idea is
that Kevin feige doesn't really care about whether
or not people go and do DC stuff like James Gunn
literally went and did The Suicide Squad movie
then came back to do Guardians of the Galaxy 3
in the holiday special and now he's going back
again to become the Kevin foggy of DC we have a
wonderful thing called the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special coming out we have a wonderful
thing called guardians galaxy vol 3 coming out
in May how will we have any time to work on DC
until May don't know but once he does have the
time I'll be very excited and first in line and
Kevin feige himself said that he's actually really
excited like I really want him to finish Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 first like he's got some work to
do but then after that I'm really excited to see
what he does at DC so it's the same situation with
people like Ben Affleck like oh it was so great
that version of Batman that you played can't
wait to see what kind of DC movies you direct
why don't you also come be in one of our Marvel
movies at the same time Kevin feige even said
that it was actually cool for Josh Brolin to come
back as Cable in live action after playing Thanos
so much during the infinity Saga movies Chris
Evans is a really great example that we might
actually see a cameo from him as his version of
Johnny storm in Deadpool 3. but everyone let me
know in the comments which Marvel movie would you
want to see Ben Affleck show up in during Marvel
Phase 5 or Marvel phase six they didn't say if
it was going to be a really big character or if
it'd be like a one-off thing kind of like Gore
the god butcher Christian Bale there's a bunch
of big stuff coming up I'll try to do videos for
it as fast as possible so make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss anything
click here for my brand new Loki season 2 trailer
video and click here for that new Thor 5 video and
learn what's going on with Hercules in the future
of the MCU thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!